you know when you get to this point
where you get to the end of the line
does this one always squat feel probably
dead one and then you sort of start off
again and you're okay
if you cut a turn and that one sort of
what cause it was a just a cut because
what i've got a
and it's because you haven't got this
shift with your hip
hip transplant so you're here
here
so when i turn without even stepping
back to forward
back forward
so perhaps that'll help you
in the future just think when you've got
them dead ones it's because you're more
than likely finishing
too upright
and when you turn there's nothing to
push forward because you're 50 50
there's nothing you know to go that
way we're here
because
try to remember some things i've said
when you're cutting you're in a forward
position
that means this one can turn so that
means when you turn
oh
don't worry